previously on there were many many
things that JFK did that went completely
and utterly against the military
industrial complex but once he stepped
into the Oval Office he realized
something terrifying while the US
government made it seem like nuclear war
was the last thing anyone wanted JFK
quickly discovered that behind closed
doors the guys in charge were a lot more
trigger happy remember this was a time
when most people view the Soviets as
satanic Devils that needed to be stopped
at all costs and in the eyes of the
powers that be at the time anything
short of absolute aggression towards the
Soviets was thought of as treasonous and
shockingly JFK's top military generals
actually believed that America could win
an allout nuclear war and they didn't
just believe that America could win they
actively wanted to go to war with the
Soviet Union just so they could win and
prove it and they didn't care how many
people had to die in the process in one
General's own words quote at the end of
the war if there are two Americans and
one Russian left standing we win End
quotes while another General said that
he wanted to publicly attack the Soviet
Union from quote hell to breakfast end
quotes JFK was horrified by this
realization he thought his number one
job as president would be to ensure that
a nuclear war never happened and yet
everyone around him was vying for war
before JFK was inaugurated he had been
briefed on a plan by the CIA to train
Cuban Exiles to invade Cuba to take back
their Homeland little did he know that
the CIA knew this Invasion would fail
and that the CIA was betting on him to
send in troops anyways once the invasion
did fail to save face only after the
invasion failed the JFK realized that he
had been drawn into a CIA trap JFK
realized that if he wanted a chance at
peace he would have to wage a different
kind of war against the very people in
his own government the cia's number one
enemy was now the commanderin-chief
President John F Kennedy one of JFK's
friends asked him what he thought of a
bestselling novel at the time about a
fictional military Takeover in the
United States it's possible he said but
it won't happen on my watch as the dust
settled JFK turned to one of his highest
officials in his administration and said
that he wanted to Splender the CIA in a
th piece and Scatter it to the
winds after firing the three most
powerful men in the CIA JFK then started
cutting the cia's budget hoping to reach
a 20% reduction by 1966 and from then on
instead of relying on the CIA for advice
on foreign policy he made the military
joint Chief of Staff his main advisers
because he foolishly believed that the
military would be easier to control than
the CIA oh boy was he wrong it was the
summer of 1962 a year after the Baya
piix Invasion ended in disaster one of
JFK's friends asked him what he thought
of a best-selling novel at the time
about a fictional military Takeover in
the United States JFK read the entire
book that night the very next day he
discussed the possibility of such a
military coup in America to his friends
it's possible he said it could happen in
this country but the conditions would
have to be just right if for example the
country had a young president and he had
a Bay of Pigs there would be a certain
uneasiness maybe the military would do a
little criticizing behind his back but
this would be written off as the usual
military satisfaction with civilian
control then if there were another Bay
of Pigs the reaction of the country
would be is he too young and
inexperienced the military would almost
feel that it was their patriotic
obligation to stand ready to preserve
the Integrity of the nation and only God
knows just what segment of democracy
they would be defending if they
overthrew the elected establishment
pausing for a moment he went on then if
there were a third Bay of Pigs it could
happen but it won't happen happen on my
watch JFK had just had his first Bay of
Pigs but little did he know that his
second one was just around the corner on
October 14th 1962 a U2 spy plane
carrying out surveillance over Cuba
spotted something alarming Eight medium
rage nuclear missile sites were being
built on the island the Soviets were on
America's doorstep they were about to
move nukes into Cuba behind closed doors
the CIA and Military commanders must
have been Furious if Kennedy had just
bombed Cuba and sent in reinforcements
when they asked him to the first time
none of this would have happened well
the military fed over JFK's refusal to
bomb Cuba the president decided to take
things into his own hands JFK secretly
reached out to Nikita kushev the leader
of the Soviet Union hoping to convince
him to remove his weapons on that same
day kushev reached out to JFK asking to
work together to resolve the crisis
JFK's generals were getting more and
more Ane and then it
happened on October 27th an American U2
spy plane was shot down over Cuba and
his Pilot killed it sent the military
into overdrive couldn't that Kennedy see
what was happening the Soviets just took
the first shot it's time to attack there
was the feeling that the Noose was
tightening on all of us on Americans on
Mankind and that the bridges to escape
were crumbling Robert F Kennedy said the
drums of War were picking up pace but
once again JFK refused instead of
declaring war on Cuba and the Soviet
Union JFK met with his brother Robert F
Kennedy and together they agreed that
RFK would have an emergency meeting with
the Soviet Ambassador and atoi doberan
to send the Soviets one final plea the
president is in a grave situation and he
does not know how to get out of it we
are under very severe stress in fact we
are under pressure from our military to
use Force against Cuba we want to ask
you Mr de brinan to pass President
Kennedy's message to Chairman kusov
through unofficial channels even though
the president himself is very much
against starting a war over Cuba an
irreversible chain of events could occur
against his will if the situation
continues much longer the president is
not sure that the military will not
overthrow him and seize
[Music]
power to Cru sh the message was clear
the kennedies did not know how much
longer they could hold out against their
generals so in cia's own words we sent
the Americans a note saying that we
agreed to remove our missiles and
bombers on the condition that the
president give us his assurance that
there would be no invasion of Cuba by
the forces of the United States or
anybody else JFK agreed and the crisis
was averted JFK had just had its second
Bay of Pigs if JFK didn't know he was
alone he sure as hell did by now he
asked the secret service agent Robert
balk to bug the White House and from
then on in nearly every meeting JFK had
with his advisers he would put on a
smile and secretly press record in one
meeting in which JFK refused his
General's recommendations for a quick
and Powerful attack on Cuba the moment
JFK walked out of the room the general
started trash talking him you pulled the
rug right out from under him one said as
the other officials in the room argued
over how they were going to get him to
do what they wanted in another meeting
where a general Le was really pushing
for an attack on the Soviets in Cuba
where he was really reassuring JFK that
the Soviets wouldn't attack back JFK
would later recount this conversation
where is Aid saying can you imagine lame
saying a thing like that these brass
hats have one great advantage in their
favor if we listen to them and do what
they want us to do none of us will be
alive later to tell them that they were
wrong but little did he know that his
third Bay of Pigs was right around the
corner and this time it wasn't the
Soviets or the Cubans fault this time
JFK brought it all on himself
welcome to part three of why they wanted
him dead and this is the final element
you need to kill a
[Music]
president in the four Decades of the C
War the American government spent more
than $7 trillion buying weapons and
supplies from the military that's over
$17 trillion in today's money or as much
money as China's entire GDP and every
single last penny of those $17 trillion
went into the pockets of Defense
contractors to give you some perspective
on just how much the Cold War costs it's
estimated that it would cost the
government around $234 billion to end
poverty in America adjusted for
inflation which means America could have
solve poverty 72 times over with the
amount of money it spent on the Cold War
war that was the kind of power and suede
the defense contractors had and with all
these trillions of dollars on the table
why would any defense contractor ever
want the cold war to end all they cared
about was the American government
signing more checks for bigger and
better weapons even Douglas mon auor the
literal general of the army of the
United States knew it was all about
money quote our government has kept us
in a Perpetual state of fear with a cry
of grave National Emergency always there
has been some terrible evil at home or
some monstrous foreign power that was
going to gobble us up if we didn't
blindly rally by behind it by Furnishing
the absorbent of funds demanded and yet
in retrospect these disasters seem never
to have happened these seem to never
have been quite real End quotes and
these were the powers that be that JFK
was attacking it was early 1963 and by
now John F Kennedy had already pissed
off the CIA the US Military and now he
was going to put the final nail in his
coffin by pissing off the last corner of
the military industrial triangle the
defense contractors by 1963 JFK had
already cut military spending by nearly
half from $2.2 billion 5 years before
for to just $1.4 billion and remember
every single dollar of the military
spending he cut was a dollar that was
being taken out of the pockets of the
most powerful industry in the United
States we're talking salaries and stock
options and bonuses that JFK was taking
away from some of the most powerful
people in the world imagine how angry
the defense contractors would be today
if Trump or Biden had cut their over
$800 billion in half during a war one
could only imagine how much anger how
much hatred they had against JFK but
deep down a part of them probably
thought that maybe just maybe maybe JFK
has something up his sleeve he came from
a military family he was a war hero so
maybe all of this was just a bluff for
the Soviets maybe JFK has something
ruthless in store for the Soviets after
all there was no way he could actually
believe that we could coexist with these
subhuman Soviets now could he but the
more the defense contractor saw the more
worried they became and the final nail
in the coffin and gave what is perhaps
the most important speech in all of his
presidency I have therefore chosen this
time and
place discuss a topic on which ignorance
too often
abounds and the truth too rarely
perceived and that is the most important
topic on Earth
peace on June 10th 1963 JFK gave the
commencement speech at the American
University in Washington DC it was
supposed to be a simple feel-good
message that would make the university
graduates excited about the future but
instead JFK used this opportunity to
give one last desperate cry to the
American people what kind of a peace do
I mean and what kind of a peace do we
seek not a Pax
Americana enforced On The World by
American weapons of
war not the Peace of the Grave or the
security of the
slave I am talking about genuine
peace the kind of peace that makes life
on Earth worth
living the kind that enables men and
Nations to grow and to Hope and build a
better life for their children not
merely peace for Americans but peace for
all men and women not merely peace in
our time but peace in all time I speak
of Peace because of the new face of
war total war makes no sense in an age
where great powers can maintain
large and relatively invulnerable
nuclear forces and refuse to surrender
without resort to those forces it makes
no sense in an age where a single
nuclear weapon contains almost 10 times
the explosive force delivered by all the
Allied air forces in the second world
war it makes no sense in an age when the
deadly poisons produced by a nuclear
exchange would be carried by wind and
water and soil and seed to the Far
Corners of the globe and to Generations
yet unborn I realize the pursuit of
peace is not as dramatic as the pursuit
of War some say that it is useless to
speak of peace or World law or World
disarmament and that it will be useless
until the leaders of the Soviet Union
adopt a more enlightened attitude I hope
they do I believe we can help them do it
but I also believe that we must
re-examine our own attitudes as
individuals and as a nation there he was
standing in front of the nation and
instead of inciting fear inciting hatred
towards the comies like you were
supposed to do there he was calling for
the masses to reexamine our attitudes
towards those animals he was telling the
masses it was possible to coexist with
them what was he doing and as JFK went
on it just got worse and worse the only
major area of these negotiations where
the end is in sight yet where a fresh
start is badly needed is in a treaty to
Outlaw nuclear test the conclusion of
such a treaty so near and yet so far
would check the spiraling armed race in
one of its most dangerous areas it would
place the nuclear powers in a position
to deal more effectively with one of the
greatest hazards which man faces in
1963 the further spread of nuclear arms
it would increase our security it would
decrease the prospects of War I'm taking
this opportunity therefore to announce
two important decisions in this regard
first chairman kusov prime minister
McMillan and I have agreed that high
level discussions will shortly begin in
Moscow looking towards early agreement
on a comprehensive I Test Ban Treaty our
hopes must be tempered with the caution
of history but with our hopes go the
hopes of all mankind second to make
clear our good faith and solemn
convictions on this matter I now declare
that the United States has not proposed
to conduct nuclear tests in the
atmosphere so long as other states do
not do so we will not be the first to
resume such a declaration is no
substitute for a formal binding treaty
but I hope it will help us achieve one
nor would such a treaty be a substitute
for disarmament but I hope it will help
us achieve it the United States as the
world knows will never start a war we do
not want a war we do not now expect a
war this generation of Americans has
already had enough more than enough of
war and hate and
oppression and it was in this moment
that John F Kennedy sealed his Fates in
the space of just a few minutes he
destroyed everything the military
industrial complex has spent the last 15
years building up all the fear all the
hatred all the demonization JFK was
wiping it all clean in the eyes of the
powers that be the only thing keeping
the Soviets from nuking America into
Oblivion was the fear that American
missiles would get to them first but now
here was the president himself admitting
in front of the entire world that
America would never Strike first that
America was going to bow down to the
Soviets in the eyes of the powers that
be JFK had might as well just nuked
America himself he had committed the
ultimate Act of treason for Martin
Luther King it was his eye Have a Dream
speech that marked him for assassination
for JFK it was this speech a speech
about seeking peace the only thing the
military industrial complex had going
for them was that maybe the Soviets
thought JFK was bluffing kushev had to
be paranoid maybe he would think that
all this was a scheme to catch the
Soviet Union off guard a nuclear Test
Ban Treaty couldn't happen without the
Soviets agreeing to it and as long as
kusf didn't agree JFK would be forced to
continue with the arms race but
unfortunately for the military indust
complex luck was not on their
[Music]
side is it a paranor and suspicion quote
Nikita kusf was deeply moved by JFK
speech he told tban negotiator AO Herman
that Kennedy had given the greatest
speech by any American president since
Roosevelt and if you remember from part
two Cru chef and gfk have been talking
to each other through Secret Letters for
months just so they could make sure no
one was listening in on both sides in
that time they had gotten to know each
other as humans instead of just world
leaders so that is how kushev knew that
JFK meant every word he said in that
peace speech he even had a transcript of
the speech translated into Russian so
that he could spread it throughout the
region so that everyone could see for
themselves what JFK had said which is
why on July 25th 1963 the United States
and the Soviet Union signed the Limited
Test band treaty outlawing nuclear test
in the atmosphere Beyond its limits
including outer space or underwater now
all that was left was for the Senate to
approve the treaty if they approved it
the test ban will move forward and peace
might actually be on the horizon but not
if the military industrial complect had
anything to do with it even after
everything even after all of JFK's talks
about peace on September 12th 1963 his
military Chiefs tried one last time to
get him to literally nuke the Soviets
first and if they're willing to kill
billions of people like that what would
those same men be willing to do to just
one man in their way but this only made
JFK more determined to push the Test Ban
through JFK told his St that the treaty
was the most serious Congressional issue
he ever faced he was he said determined
to win even if it cost him the 1964
election this was it this was JFK's
defining moment as a president and there
was no way he was going to back down now
so for 2 months JFK focused all his time
and energy on convincing Americans that
signing the treaty was the right thing
to do and on September 23rd 1963 the US
Senate agreed with them the testb treaty
was approved by a
landslide JFK ad dunets he had brought
America one massive step closer to peace
without ever having to fire a single
Bullets by now JFK knew there was no
turning back he had shown his cars as
clear as day to the military-industrial
complex and now they were out for his
head so JFK just doubled down fighting
harder than ever for peace instead of
just dealing with Nikita kushev JFK was
also sending representatives to Fidel
Castro as well hoping they could
convince him to agree to peace too just
like the Soviets did and then came his
trip to Dallas Texas on November 21 1963
right before leaving on his strip to
Texas JFK told his assistant press
secretary that his next Target once he
got back was to finish the Vietnam
ordeal once and for all after I come
back from Texas that's going to change
Vietnam is not worth another American
life he said and then that's when it
happened
just 5 months after JFK gave his
Infamous speech calling for peace John F
Kennedy was dead a flash from Dallas two
priests who were with President Kennedy
say he is dead a years ago the nation
watched as our 35th President John F
Kennedy was laid to rest at Arlington
National Cemetery a lone gunman murders
the president of the United States and
then less than 48 hours later that lone
gunman is himself murdered by another
lone gunman what are the odds of that
and that second lone gunman he was a guy
named Jack Ruby Jack Ruby was caught
murdering Lee Harvey oswal on live TV so
the verdict seemed obvious but for some
reason soon after getting sent to jail
his conviction was mysteriously
overturned on appeal he had literally
shot and killed a man on live TV in
front of dozens of police and Witnesses
but he was somehow not guilty of murder
something was not right and what do you
know right before his retrial started
giving him a chance to rethink his
confession Jack Ruby died of pulmonary
embolism or a blockage of arteries that
send blood to your lungs wow how
convenient he was then taken to the same
Hospital JFK and Oswald were taken to
where he was declared dead and with the
lone G that murdered the president dead
and the lone G that murdered the lone
Gman also dead there was no one left to
blame and most importantly there was no
one left to fight for Peace So the
military-industrial complex was finally
free to do as they pleased and what do
you know just 2 years later America
officially entered the Vietnam War and
things just escalated from
there it would take another 28 years and
trillions of dollars sent out the
pockets of a select fuel for the Cold
War to finally come to an anti-climatic
end which seems like the most
appropriate ending because as Douglas my
author once said always there has been
some monstrous foreign power that was
going to gobble us up if we did not
blindly rally behind the government by
Furnishing the exorbitant funds demanded
and yet in retrospect these disasters
never seem to have happened they seem to
have never in quite real end
quote but here's the thing as you can
imagine JFK's death was far from the
first or only thing the CIA covered up
just take a look at what this former
LAPD detective had to say about the CIA
back in
1996 I will tell you director deuts has
a former Los Angeles police narcotics
detective that the agency has dealt
drugs throughout this country for a long
time director deuts I will refer you to
three specific agency operations known
as Amadeus Pegasus and Watchtower I have
Watchtower documents heavily redacted by
the agency I was personally exposed to
CIA operations and recruited by CIA
Personnel who attempted to recruit me in
the late ' 70s to become involved in
protecting agency drug operations in
this country I have been trying to get
this out for 18 years and I have the
evidence my question for you is very
specific sir if in the course of the
ig's investigations and Fred hit's work
you come across evidence of severely
criminal activity let him speak and it's
classified will you use that
classification to hide the criminal
activity or will you tell the American
people the truth yes he accused the CIA
of trafficking drugs onto the streets of
America but is there any truth to this
would the CIA really intentionally get
Americans addicted to crack cocaine well
we looked into it and as it turns out
yes there is a whole mountain of
evidence literal CIA operations of them
trafficking drugs in fact this is what
Chris Milligan a writer publisher and
the son of the ca officer who has spent
years investigating the link between the
CIA and drug trafficking had to say
about it do I think the CIA is still
trafficking drugs today yes I do uh but
I think that there's also a lot more
people trafficking drugs most every
intelligence agency and we expose it all
in our new private documentary that you
can watch right now by clicking the card
on the screen this is part of our
YouTube membership where we post only
the most controversial documentaries way
too spicy to be posted publicly we've
got a ton of great ones out already
these are videos you would never see
posted anywhere else and you are going
to love this one on CIA drug trafficking
so click the card on the screen to watch
now and as always stay
dangerous